Пором на цьому місці є з 1973 року.
Раніше він був вище за течією, десь на 200 м.
Тут був зручніший підйом
і було як зафіксувати трос,
за допомогою якого він
тримається в одному положенні,
не спливаючи вище за течією чи нижче.
В буденні дні я переплавляю 20-30 людей.
А в «базарні» дні і 200, і 300 людей буває.
Заходять люди, відштовхую від берега
і далі штовхаю пором.
Підтягую одну лебідку — змінюю кут, положення порому,
щоб течія його штовхала.
І все.
Змінив кут, щоб течія допомагала.
Великої арифметики нема — все залежить від кута.
Як поставиш кут.
От ми зараз розвернули передньою частиною,
підняли її вперед.
Коли течія іде вниз,
вона впирається у борт і штовхає пором.
Завдяки тросу він має спрямований рух
в одну сторону.
Змінюємо кут — іде в іншу сторону.
Тут небезпечного нема, це, як то кажуть,
«поплавок на човні» стоїть прив'язаний.
Наше селище як півострів і тільки одна дорога,
тож пором нас дуже виручає.
Більшість, хто їде до Львова чи Тернопіля,
їдуть через пором, бо так ближче.
Треба або круг через Хотин робити,
або тут переїхати — і вже Тернопільська область.
Це ж тут Тернопільщина, а їдуть з Буковини.
Це мій паром.
Я його з татом робив.
Стали й подумали: а що робити?
Пара рублів була, чим займатися?
Десь їхати на заробітки?
Не хотілося, бо, як то кажуть,
коло хати й камінь обростає. Так само й ми.
Це ж воєнні понтони. Воєнні мости.
В Кам'янці купили.
У військовій частині.
Ту частину розформували.
Машини забрали до Києва, а понтони стояли,
їх списували на металобрухт.
Тут був нижче маленький пором в іншому селі.
Я лише подивився на нього,
очима сфотографував,
і більшого лекала мені не треба було.
Понтон один складається із чотирьох секцій.
Одна секція, друга секція, третя та четверта.
Всередині все пустотіле.
І вони на плаву стоять.
Вода може бути навіть на поромі.
І він буде йти. Його троси тримають.
Тут треба, щоб була рівна площа опори.
А тоді вода сама штовхає пором.
Якби вода не штовхала пором — то інша річ.
Він би стояв на місці.
Його можна поставити рівно
серед Дністра і він стоїть собі,
навіть ні вправо, ні вліво не буде їхати.
От найгірше — це заїзди.
Якщо вода падає і піднімається,
до берега можеш не дійти,
бо тут треба вгадати такий нахил,
щоб пором підходив до самого шутру.
А як до шутру доходить,
то людина зійде й не намочить туфлі собі,
і машина з'їде нормально.
Якщо вода мілка, то він іде поволі.
А якщо вода піднімається —
йде трошки швидше і ліпше для порома.
За 10 хвилин він Дністер перепливає.
Тут ширина Дністра 250 м.
Щороку пором проходить техогляд.
Техпаспорт є в нього.
Раз на п'ять років перереєстрація, заміна техпаспорту.
Перевіряється дієздатність порому.
У документах пише: «Має право плавати
по водній карті України під державним прапором».
Пором бере груз не менше 40 тонн.
40 тонн заїжджають і вільно перепливають.
Ще й запас 20 см лишається.
Є сполучення з одним селом, з іншим селом.
З одним районом, з іншим районом.
Людям добре зробили, бо зараз з цього села,
щоб до нас у село переїхати кругом,
через міст у Заліщиках, треба не менше 62 км проїхати.
А тут кілька метрів переїхав і вже в селі.
І людям легше.
До Чернівецької області звідси везуть продукцію
і не їдуть зайвих 40 км.
Я вам скажу так: на мою думку,
коли міст буде, буде сполучення
одного району з іншим районом,
більше народу буде перетинати,
буде робота в людей, і будуть перспективи ближче.
Люди приїжджатимуть, будуть спілкуватися, працювати...
Як-то кажуть, це краще для людей буде.
Хто думав, що я це буду робити?
Ніколи не думав замолоду.
Але старість прийшла, зробили тут трохи.
І вже по-тихеньку 10 років плаваємо.